Okay, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p here
is an example of a Trumpist who is so, so
deep in conspiracy and bogus talking points
that I don't really know how to reply to them,
but I do want to let you know that these people
exist and they're allowed to vote, which is
why we need to vote to counteract them.
Take a listen.
He, I'm watching the show right now and a
totally about president Trump and president
Obama.
President Trump is probably one of the best
person we've ever had, and I don't want to
say that wire's just studied.
Just, just wake up and see it.
When Obama was president, we had been infiltrated
at the highest level and you guys never caught
on to that.
But looking at everything he did, it was not,
none of it was pro USA.
He are better or enemies or ran.
Yeah.
He webinars the MPI, the spa.
Hilary was selling our uranium.
That's for nuclear weapons.
They were, he Abello they were fun.
There are military there.
Make your countries right for pigging.
Thank God.
[inaudible] we will for president Trump.
Have a good day.
Yeah.
I have no response other than to say that's
what we're fighting against.
Okay.
You can't convince that person to vote for
someone other than Trump.
They may live in a state where it doesn't
really matter because Trump's going to carry
the state.
Our focus needs to be find reasonable people
and tell them it's really important to vote
because you are not going to convince that
Trumpist mess who has devolved into all sorts
of ridiculous conspiracies, uh, to reconsider
his opinion.
Okay.
It's get out the vote, not convinced Trumpists
to vote for a democrat.
That's not the name of the game.
Grey bonus show.
Today we'll talk about Boris Johnson becoming
the British prime minister.
We will talk about a $700 million settlement
for Equifax after this massive breach.
I actually, my
my identity identity has been pseudo stolen,
I believe, as a result of that, a breach.
I'll talk about it on the governance show
today.
Get access to the bonus show.
Become a member or a patron.
I'll speak to you